もういいですか？
結構多いっすよね
マジか～
僕の背位ありますよ
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
僕には夢がたくさんある
その夢の１つとして、ブロックで家を作ってみたかった
今日はその念願の夢が叶うときがついに来ました
1300くらい
1300個ブロックを準備して頂きました
いま朝っぱらなんですけど
果たして日が暮れるまでに僕が
ブロックで家を作りきれるかどうかっていう問題もあるので
時間との戦いになりそうです
ブロックは3種類あって
これをうまいこと使い分けていかに家にしていくかがポイントです
とりあえず壁はバッと1回作ります
では行こう！！
よっしゃーやるぞ
よっしゃぁ
でも笑ってられないんスよね
時間との勝負ですから、一刻を争います
ひとまず後ろの壁は完成しました
たぶんこれがベースになると思います
ちょっと窓作ります
うわぁ！
いや、想定内
細かいブロックもあるんで、それを上手く使えば余裕で作れます
すいません！
少しブロックが足りなくなってきました
このまま作ると多分家が作れないんで
壁のあたりをちょっと削ります
辛いぜ！！
ドアこんな感じです。上は後で作ります
よし、たぶんブロックは足りるんで
後はひたすら壁の高さを上げていきます
太陽がまぶしいぜ
はい、というわけで無事ブロックの家完成しました！
屋根を作ると危ないので出来なかったんですけども
もうパッと見完全に部屋はブロックだらけでできております
こういう感じで僕のペットのグリフォンとかね
クリーパーとか、ソファとか机もできました！
こういう感じでブロックの家の中にも色々できました！
すごい時間がかかってギリギリだったんですけど
完璧なつくりなので、なんとか間に合ってよかったです
というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
ブロックで家をつくってみた
もう生活ができるような感じだと思うので
しばらく僕はこの家で生活していこうと思います
では、また。